welcome to my desktop today we are gonna
talk about main loops and one of the
main uses you see of the while loop in
every pretty much every program
so what we're gonna do here is we're
going to build from scratch using Visual
Studio here
we're gonna build from scratch a while
loop that infinitely does stuff until
you tell it to leave so we're just
giving it a name
and you can follow along exactly if you
want but ultimately the names of things
don't really matter it's this concept of
the loop of that matters but if you want
to get to exactly where I'm at here sure
follow up so now that we're in our new
project I like to show all files here
here because it's just easier to tell
what's going on but really what we want
to do is just add a class so I'm gonna
put this main while loop in a class
think of this as like the center of your
app where everything along that is
checked so you want to bring it all
together in this sort of file and I'm
doing it as if in a class just because
it's C++ and this is sort of a standard
practice you could just do this all in
functions if you want
there we go
okay and now we're just gonna add a main
file named LCVP so we have an entry
point from when we press our
and now we're just going to take some
time to build up these files so starting
from these three we can get a while loop
going
that we could use for the core of
anything being a game
something that
does something until you close the
program
[Music]
I think what we're gonna do here is just
make a
a processor
just a character processor so this sort
of thing could be used to parse some
text but it isn't really the lip is just
showing the concept
[Music]
so I'm thinking here on a return
whatever this main returns so I'm just
gonna call it stack here
our mainly
it's gonna have a run function
well this is a mainland class so we need
to build it up so it handles a
you know you might have a better name
for your class once you know exactly
what it does but this is just an example
so what I'm actually doing here with
this get instance function that
statically returns the pointer to this
class is making in a single time and
also I want to be able to type them run
main loop to just do everything
so I'm just gonna make this a back
so anytime you include this may look
better but also get this macro
and that'll save us some character
typing as you can see it's a bit of
[Music]
extra text to do the old getinstance run
which might just you know just looks
scary saver
so in this kid instance we're going to
need to
our main variable and we're gonna do it
actually has a unique pointer this will
allocate the main loop on the stack or
I'm sorry the heap and we'll also take
care of deallocating since it's a unique
pointer names are hard I can't call it
main loop cuz well sorry the name how
about just ml no in blue maybe it
doesn't even matter you just gotta give
it a name
let's go ahead and make unique so we do
this all in the
get instance function since it's static
had only instantiates the very first
time then of course returns mainly so no
matter how many times you call main loop
it's only gonna create the main loop
class once and then just return it
and everything looks pretty good there
let's make sure the section returns a
pointer
okay well now that we've got a way to
access it as a singleton let's make our
run function and I should say the reason
this is a singleton is because we don't
want more than one instance of it ever
created there may be other cases that
you can come up with where you don't
want it to be a singleton but it's just
for example here so here we're making a
while loop and it runs while true which
is what that one is and it just
basically says the loop is running in
this way let's include iostream of
course you need that so when we hit play
here it should hit our main and just run
this loop and as you can see is just
going through it at many times since I
have no condition for it to stop it'll
just go until I close it so what we
could do to further this long
well we've shown the main part okay so
this is how you're on an infinite loop
this is how you doing a single to class
but now you need some states you need
some sort of we'll say a state machine
it might not be the perfect word for
this scenario but basically you can
design some sort of state machine and
your Wilder process is based on it we're
gonna make a character choice and we're
just gonna grab from the user every loop
a new character and we're gonna say if
they put in this tilde then it'll exit
the program so that's gonna be our
ending Clause just because there's got
to be something and no one ever presses
that key unless they're very
intentionally doing so there's probably
a better way to accident so let's just
say enter a character and then
we'll take from the user a character so
now on this while live goes what's gonna
happen is every loop it's gonna sit at
this choice as long as there's nothing
in the stream and it's gonna wait for
something in that input stream and then
we're just gonna say here what was last
processed since we're seeing just one
character it is literally only gonna
take one character out of the stream at
a time then we're gonna just say after
the loop or after they press it that it
was processed now also this allows us to
do something else as long as we're in
this loop it's just going to keep taking
characters and spitting them out and we
can decide what we want to do with those
we can add up to a string maybe you want
an entry field or something on your
program you can essentially do it with
this loop you don't need all these C
outs of course but just for example you
can see I'm spamming keys here and it is
processing them all so if you're looking
for text input this is basically all you
gotta do just take these characters and
processing as needed as they use their
interesting
that's pretty much it if you like this
and please consider subscribing
I also have a patreon I could use any
support I can get over there
it means a lot I will add you to the
credits videos
it would be a teacher and will come up
more stuff later peace out